conference have already been sent out
and so for the members and the
representatives of the media please do
indicate the name of your organization
your own name and the question you have
i would like to also stress that
we will try to accommodate as many
questions as possible we will have about
90 minutes for the entire press
conference
but
it is likely that unfortunately we will
not be able to go through all of them i
would like now to welcome mr abdullah
moxie the secretary of the ipcc to
introduce today's event and speakers
thank you dear andre andre today
the ipcc releases its report on the
mitigation
of climate change
soon you will hear from the scientists
themselves when they present the main
funding of this report
this cycle
the sixth cycle was the most intense of
all the ipcc history with eight reports
and we have already released seven of
them
we have finalized
the reports from the
three working groups
in unprecedented
condition during the covid
19 pandemic
the report
released today comes at the end of the
this
third successful
virtual
approver binary i mean virtual approval
plenary
the commitments
and years of hard work of
of scientists around the world and night
195
government made this possible
let me also stress
that the ipcc ability to deliver
rely on the voluntary
and generous contribution of states
i am incredibly honored to welcome and
introduce
our distinguished
guest speakers
first
we will see the video message from the
united nations secretary general antonio
gutierrez
we will also hear from
our ipcc chair
professor hussorli
we will also hear from the world
meteorological organization secretary
general professor peter talas and
the united nations environment program
executive director inger anderson
we will also hear from the scientists
dr jimsky
co-chair of working group 3
we'll hear also from professor diana or
vorsats
vice
chair of working group 3 and we will
hear also from
dr ramon
peach madruga
vice chair of working group
working group 3
we will now see the video message from
the united nations secretary general
antonio gutierrez
the jury has reached the verdict and it
is damning
this report of the intergovernmental
panel on climate change is a litany of
broken climate promises
it is a file of shame
cataloging the empty pledges that put us
firmly on track towards an unbelievable
world
we are on a fast track to climate
disaster
measures heat is underwater
unprecedented waves terrifying storms
widespread water shortages the
extinction of a million species of
plants and animals
and these is not fiction or exaggeration
it is what science tells us will result
from our current energy policies
we are on a pathway to global warming of
more than doubled 1.5 degree limit
agreed in paris
some government and business leaders are
saying one thing but doing another
simply put
they are lying
and the results will be catastrophic
this is a climate emergency
climate scientists warned that we are
already perilously close to tipping
points that could lead to cascading and
irreversible climate impacts
but highly meeting governments and
corporations are not just turning a
blind eye
they are adding full to the flames
they are choking our planet based on
their vested interests and historic
investments in fossil fuels
when cheaper renewable solutions provide
green jobs energy security and greater
price stability
we left cop26 in glasgow with a naive
optimism based on new promises and
commitments
but the main problem
the enormous growing emissions gap was
all but ignored
and the science is clear
to keep 1.5 degree limit agreed in paris
within reach we need to club global
emissions by 45 percent this decade
but current climate pledges would mean a
14 percent increase in emissions
and most major emitters are not taking
the steps needed to fulfill even these
inadequate promises
climate activists are sometimes depicted
as dangerous radicals
but the truly dangerous radicals are the
countries that are increasing the
production of fossil fuels
investing in new fossil fuel
infrastructure is moral and economic
madness
such investments will soon be stranded
assets a blot on the landscape and the
blight on investment portfolios
but it doesn't have to be this way
today's report is focused on mitigation
cutting emissions it sets out viable
financially sound options in every
sector that can keep the possibility of
limiting warming to 1.5 degrees alive
first and foremost we must triple the
speed of the shift to renewable energy
and that means moving investments and
subsidies from fossil fuels to
renewables now
in most cases renewables are already far
cheaper
it means governments ending the funding
of coal not just abroad but at home
and it means climate coalitions made out
of developed countries multilateral
development banks private financial
institutions and corporations with
adequate technologies supporting major
economic emerging economies in making
this shift
it means protecting forests and
ecosystems as powerful climate solutions
it means rapid progress in reducing
methane emissions and it means
implementing the pledges made in paris
and glasgow
leaders must lead
but all of us can do our part we all
adapt to young people civil society and
indigenous communities for sounding the
alarm and holding leaders accountable
we need to build on their work to create
a grassroots movement that cannot be
ignored
if you live in a big city a rural area
or a small island state
if you invest in the stock market if you
care about justice and our children's
future i am appealing directly to you
demand that renewable energy is
introduced now at speed and at scale
demand an end to coal-fired power
demand an end to all fossil fuel
subsidies
today's report comes at the time of
global turbulence inequalities are at
unprecedented levels the recovery from
the cov19 pandemic is scandalously
uneven
inflation is rising
and war in ukraine is causing food and
energy prices to skyrocket
but increasing fossil fuel production
will only make matters worse
choices made by countries now
will make or break the commitment to 1.5
degrees
a shift to renewables will mend our
broken global energy mix and offer hope
to millions of people suffering climate
impacts today
climate promises and plans must be
turned into reality and action now
it's time to stop burning our planet and
start investing in the abundant
renewable energy all around us
now invite the chair of the ipcc dr
hoison lee to take the floor
we have just heard a very important
message from the united nations
secretary general antonio guterres
the ipcc report before us today
is a powerful evidence that we have the
great potential to mitigate climate
change
we are at a crossroads this is the time
for action
we have the tools and know how to limit
warming and secure a livable future
today's report marks the completion of
the scientific trilogy it is the last
piece of the three ipcc working group
contributions to the sixth assessment
report
which will conclude with a synthesis
report to be released later this year
this working group 3 report provides the
most recent scientific knowledge on the
mitigation of climate change
it complements the report on the state
of global warming
which was released last summer
and the report on the climate risks and
adaptation released just last month
together they confirmed that ipcc is the
authoritative scientific voice of the
united nations on climate change and
that the ipcc is the unique interface
between climate science and policy
making
i'm confident that
the policy makers around the world
especially the cop27 in egypt later this
year
will benefit greatly from the four ipcc
reports and that these reports will be
the backbone of the climate
deliberations decision making and action
on a global regional and national level
thank you
thank you dr lee uh we will now see a
video message from the wmo secretary
general peter de talas
very high on the global agenda as well
here uh participants of the of the ipcc
working group 3 press conference via tim
skier
you have been heading the writing team
and i'd like to thank also the uk
government for the all the support that
you have given
even for the for the success of this uh
report
but the the road has been a bit bumpy
and and you have been forced to work
much harder than you expected but i
think the end result is great
we are at the moment facing very
challenging times we we have learned
from the about this brutal war in
ukraine which also has
has an impact on the media environment
and that has meant that attention to
this long-term
major challenge for the for the welfare
of human and kind and biosphere has been
a little bit lower than than it used to
be before this war
and this war that is ongoing in ukraine
it has an impact also outside of ukraine
has an impact on food security prices of
food and also prices of energy
and and this is going to hit especially
less developed countries as is the case
of
climate change as well
we have already seen a rises of energy
prices both electricity and fossil fuels
and
and that's very high on the global
agenda as well
and and
and in the best case this would
speed up
reduction of the use of fossil energy
and also speed up green transition
in the worst case interest to mitigate
climate change
will be challenged because of this
this
development but let's concentrate on the
on the results of this excellent report
which form very good basis for crucially
needed
ways of the ambition level of climate
mitigation
although uh uh i would like to embrace
the the results of the cop 26 uh where
g7 and european union countries made
blazes to keep us on 1.5 degrees track
we should also keep in mind that the
rest of the g20 countries including the
brics countries were not in a position
to
to offer such glitches that would keep
us on on such a track
his report today shows
what are the means and most effective
means
and most affordable means in different
types of economies to enhance the
crucial immediate
pace of mitigation efforts i hope that
this is this information will be used by
the governments
in different parts of the world to
proceed
with mitigation
the working group 2
report which was published some weeks
ago
was showing that every corner of the
earth is already affected by climate
change
and report today
shows that every region in the world
has also an impact on climate change
problem today
classically we have been thinking that
the only the developed countries
which have used most of the fossil
resources so far are responsible for for
that but if we take the land use into
account especially deforestation
in latin america africa and southern
asia
it's shown that they have also had a
major impact on
on the climate problem which is
demonstrating that we need
global efforts to be successful in
climate
climate mitigation
and besides that there's also need to uh
pay attention to climate adaptation we
know that the negative trend in climate
will continue for the coming decades
anyhow and melting of glaciers and sea
level rise for the coming coming
centuries
it's a celebrated world meteorological
day on 23rd of march and and their
united nations secretary general antonia
guterres
was tasking wmo to to lead the
preparation of major early warning
service packets
to be approved by the cop 27 hosted by
egypt this november in summer's sake
only half of the 193 members of wmo have
proper early warning services in praise
which means that the ever-growing
impacts are causing
dramatically
causing dramatically growing economic
and human losses
we have also drastic gaps in weather
climate and hydrological observing
systems
which means that early warning services
especially in african caribbean pacific
countries
are in very poor shape
there's an urgent need to invest in
basic better climate and water observing
infrastructures to enhance the early
warning service abilities of especially
ldc and sids countries
un aims at reaching 100 global coverage
of early warning services by the end of
2028 to investments and capacity
building of meteorological climate and
hydrological infrastructures and
education of related national
expertise
so to conclude we have two words and
challenges ahead of us
adaptation and mitigation both financing
missionary political decisions
and concrete actions are needed for the
sake of the welfare of current and
future generations and our biosphere
thank you
i would now kindly invite inge anderson
the unep the united nations environment
program executive director to take the
flow
thank you so much and to all members of
the press welcome and of course
to uh husong lee who's the chair of ipcc
and certainly to jim skier diana urged
wasats and ramen picks madruga who is
first
co-chair and vice chairs
of this working group
today we present an important report
part of the trilogy
that
petry referenced in his recording
as you know this is the third report
from the ipcc during this current access
assessment cycle and it now completes
the full picture
of the climate crisis that is facing
humanity
and as we heard from the secretary
general it is not a pretty picture
the first two ipcc reports told us that
climate change is here
and now
and causing huge disruptions in the
natural world and to human well-being
this report tells us that we're still
not doing enough to cut greenhouse gas
emissions confirming the findings of
uneps 2021
emissions gap report
the last two decades saw the highest
increase in emissions in human history
even though we know how much trouble
we're in
the next decade cannot follow the same
pattern if we are to hold warming this
century to 1.5 degrees celsius
health measures will not half greenhouse
gas emissions by 2030 which is what we
need to do
and we all need to go in on this
the ipcc tells us that we have the
knowledge and the technology to get this
done
through a rapid shift from fossil fuels
to renewable and alternative fuels
through moving from deforestation to
restoration
through backing nature in our landscapes
oceans and cities
through transforming our cities into
green and clean spaces
and through behavior changes to address
the demand side of the equation
now such an opportunity did present
itself when countries rolled off their
docket stimulus packages to help
kick-start economies when we faced covet
19 pandemic
but on the green scorecard we failed
loud and clear
once again we now today find ourselves
with an opportunity for some as
countries seek out alternative sources
of energy
immediate needs must be met yes to heat
homes and to keep lights on but as we
rethink hydrocarbon suppliers our depend
and our dependency on fossil fuels the
solution has to be
to kick start the transition to
renewable and cleaner sources of energy
the next climate comp in xiaomi
must bring more ambitious climate
pledges
and long-term strategies for 2050 to
help drive such shifts
but increased action must begin
this year not next year this month not
next month and indeed today not tomorrow
otherwise we will as the u.n secretary
general put it continue to sleepwalk
into a climate catastrophe thank you
thank you very much for these thoughtful
remarks i would now like to invite dr
hosten lee the chair of the ipcc to open
the official presentation of the report
thank you andre this critically
important working group 3 contribution
assesses progress made in mitigation and
options available for the future
it is looking at enabling conditions
across sectors and systems in the
aspects of the technological
environmental economic and social
dimensions
building on the findings of working
group 1 and working group 2 this report
gives us options for solution
it offers strategies to tackle the
critical questions of our time
how can the world reduce greenhouse gas
emissions how can the world speed up the
emissions of emissions reductions in a
just and equitable manner
how can the buildings transport cities
agriculture livestock and energy sector
to be a part of the solutions to
lowering emissions
i'm encouraged by the increasing number
of countries taking ambitious climate
actions there are policies regulations
and market instruments that are proving
effective
if these are scaled up and applied more
widely
they can support deep emissions
reductions and
stimulate innovation
the working group 3 co-chairs and vice
chairs will present the main findings of
the report
now i hand over to the working group
three co-chair dr jim ski who will
present the details of the report
okay thank you uh hussain and before i
start i would like to thank all of the
authors who spent countless hours
working on this report on a voluntary
basis under extremely difficult
circumstances uh given the covered
pandemic i would also like to thank my
fellow co-chair priya darshay p r shukla
who unfortunately can't be with us uh
today we've actually been shoulder to
shoulder for the last five years to
guide the work on this report
in his place i'm actually joined by two
of the working group three vice chairs
deanna urga versats and ramon peaks
madruga and together we are pleased to
present the findings of this working
group three assessment of the mitigation
of climate change
now our assessment was prepared by
278 authors from 65 countries
we reviewed more than 18 000 scientific
papers and considered close to sixty
thousand individual comments from
governments and experts as part of the
drafting process and all of this
feedback has helped to strengthen the
report
so in the next 20 minutes we're going to
set out our key findings showing where
we are in terms of greenhouse gas
emissions
where we're headed and what action we
can take to limit global warming
now the reality
is that greenhouse gases missions which
are causing global warming are at their
highest levels in human history
emissions in 2019 were about 12
higher than they were in 2010 and 54
higher than in 1990
so we are definitely not on track to
limit warming to 1.5 degrees celsius
but there is increased evidence of
climate action and the average annual
rate of growth in global emissions has
slowed in the last decade from 2.1 per
year in the early part of this century
to 1.3 per year between 2010 and 2019
and this decline in growth is
particularly noticeable in the energy
and industry sectors where the rate of
growth has more than halved
despite this progress our assessment
concludes that unless there are
immediate and deep emission reductions
across all sectors limiting warming to
1.5 degrees will be beyond reach
some countries have achieved a steady
decrease in emissions over several years
at rates consisting consistent with
limiting warming to two degrees and a
growing number of cities are setting net
zero target
an increased range of policies and laws
have enhanced energy efficiency reduced
rates of deforestation and accelerated
the deployment of renewable energy
and climate laws that result in reduced
or avoided emissions are present in 56
countries covering more than half of
global emissions
one notable success is around renewable
energy
since 2010 there have been sustained
decreases in unit costs with reductions
of 85 percent for solar energy
55 for wind power and 85 percent for
batteries and in some cases costs have
fallen below those of fossil fuels
and at the same time we've seen big
increases in installed capacity
as this figure
figure shows
now looking at policies that were
implemented by december 2020
we conclude that without strengthening
mitigation efforts greenhouse gas
emissions are projected to lead to
warming of 3.2
degrees
in the scenarios we assessed limiting
warming to 1.5 degrees requires global
greenhouse gas emissions to peak before
2025 at the latest and be reduced by 43
by 2030
emissions from methane a short-lived but
very potent greenhouse gas would also
need to be reduced by about a third over
the same period
and even if we do this it is almost
inevitable that we will at least
temporarily exceed 1.5 degrees warming
but we could return below this level by
the end of the century
now limiting warming to around 2 degrees
still requires global emissions to peak
before 2025 at the latest and be reduced
by about a quarter by 2030
now the temperature will stabilize when
we reach net zero carbon dioxide
emissions
so to limit warming to around 1.5
degrees requires reaching net zero
carbon dioxide emissions in the early
2050s and for two degrees carbon dioxide
emissions would have to be reduced to
net zero in the early 2070s
deep and sustained reductions of other
gases would also be required
so how do we go about reducing these
emissions and to answer this question
let me hand over to diana
thank you jim
i'm deanna urger forzat one of the vice
chairs of working group three
what i would like to do now is to take
you through the options that are
available in each sector to combat
climate change
and yes in every sector there are
options available
that can at least have emissions by 2030
and keep open the possibility of
limiting warming to 1.5 degrees
let's walk through these
the energy sector accounts for about a
third of all emissions and major
transitions are required to limit global
warming
this will involve a substantial
reduction in fossil fuel use
low or no carbon energy systems
widespread electrification
use of alternative fuels such as
hydrogen and sustainable biofuels
use of carbon capture and storage
and improved energy efficiency
transitioning to a low carbon energy
sector
is expected to cut down international
trade in fossil fuels
energy efficiency and reductions in
energy consumption can be achieved using
using digital technologies
in this way it is also possible to
decentralize an energy network
so that power comes from multiple
localized energy networks rather than
one main electricity grid
electricity systems powered by
renewables are becoming increasingly
viable
but it will be challenging to supply the
entire energy system in this way
changes to our lifestyles and behavior
can reduce our carbon footprint as well
as improve our health and well-being
there is untapped potential here to
bring down global emissions by between
40 and 70
by 2050
but only if the necessary policies
infrastructure and technologies are in
place
of the 60 actions we assessed in this
report on an individual level the
biggest contribution comes from
switching to walking and cycling
and using electrified transport
other effective options include reducing
air travel
and adapting our houses
shifting towards balanced plant-based
diets is an option
wealthier individuals have the highest
potential for reductions
as investors
consumers
role models
and professionals
while there is mitigation potential in
many regions of the world
in some places people require additional
housing
energy and resources for human
well-being
to be effective lifetime changes will
need to be supported by systemic changes
across every aspect of society
including transport
buildings
industry and land use
looking at the transport sector reducing
demand plays an important part in
reducing emissions and low carbon
technologies are also key
electric vehicles offer the greatest
potential as long as they are combined
with low or zero carbon electricity
sources
advances in battery technologies could
assist in the electrification of trucks
and complement conventional electric
rail systems
in aviation and shipping
which are harder to decarbonize
alternative fuels
such as low emission hydrogen and
biofuels would be needed
overall there is substantial potential
for emissions reductions but this
depends on decarbonizing the power
sector
cities and other urban areas account for
more than two-thirds of global emissions
if we take into account what is produced
in the city and brought in from
elsewhere through energy and products
and there is significant potential for
emissions reductions
in all cities better urban planning is
key three other broad strategies have
been found to be effective
these include
sustainable consumption and production
of goods and services
electrification
and improving carbon uptake and storage
in cities
for example with trees
lakes
green roofs and permeable surfaces
in buildings it is possible to reach net
zero emissions in 2050
action in this decade is critical
to fully capture this potential
this will involve retrofitting existing
buildings and using effective mitigation
technologies in those that are yet to be
built
this requires ambitious policy packages
which may incorporate efficient design
and use of space
energy materials
appliances
and the use of renewables
there is an increasing number of net
zero and net zero net zero energy and
net zero carbon buildings in almost all
climates
this has come about from construction
and retrofitting
more could be done to reduce emissions
in this sector if renovation rates and
retrofitting were improved
reducing emissions in industry will
involve using materials and energy more
efficiently
reusing and recycling products and
minimizing waste
these approaches are underused in
policies and industrial practice at
present
for basic materials including steel
building materials and chemicals
low to zero greenhouse gas production
processes are their pilot or near
commercial stage
in some cases they are at commercial
stage but not yet established through
industrial practice
this sector accounts for about a quarter
of global emissions
achieving net zero will be challenging
and will require new production
processes
low and zero emissions electricity
hydrogen and where necessary carbon
capture and storage
to counterbalance how to limit hard to
eliminate emissions for example from
agriculture aviation and some industrial
processes
requires carbon dioxide removal
these methods remove carbon dioxide from
the atmosphere and store it on land
underground
or in the ocean
there are biological methods that can
store carbon such as reforestation
and soil carbon management
and these are widely practiced
new technologies such as direct air
capture and storage require more
research
upfront investment and proof of concept
of larger scales
before they can be widely used
carbon dioxide removal
is essential to achieve net zero
for carbon dioxide removal to work
effectively agreed methods for measuring
reporting and verification verification
are required
and finally
agriculture forestry and other land use
can provide large-scale emissions
reductions and remove and store carbon
dioxide at scale
this can be done by protecting
and restoring natural ecosystems
including forests peatlands coastal
wetlands savannas and grasslands
improved and sustainable crop and
livestock management can also play a
part
land
provides us with so much
for example food
nature
and our livelihoods
this competing demands have to be
carefully managed
but land can only do so much in terms of
removing and storing carbon and cannot
compensate for delayed emission
reductions in other sectors
to look at how we can strengthen and
restore
strength and the response and accelerate
a low carbon transition i would like to
hand over to my fellow vice chair ramon
thank you diana
my name is ramon pixel madruga vice
chair of ipcc working group 3 i'm very
pleased to
share with you
this last segment of our presentation
uh the next few years are critical if we
want to limit the warming to 1.5 degrees
celsius and what i would like to share
with you
now is uh precisely the way so some ways
on options to improve um
our chances to stay to success and i
would like to start with the finance
our assessment shows that financial
flows are a factor of three to six
times lower
than levels needed by 2030 to limit
warming to below 1.5 degrees celsius or
2 degrees celsius but there is
sufficient global capital
available and liquidity to close
investment gaps
clear signaling from government and the
international community
a strong alignment of public sector
finance and policies is critical
critically important
the challenge of closing gaps is
wireless for developing countries due to
the limited limited capacities of these
countries as particularly the less
developed countries
without taking into account the economic
benefits of reduced adaptation costs or
avoided climate impacts global gross
domestic product growth
could be
just a few percentage point lower in
2050 if we take the necessary actions to
limit warming to 2 degrees celsius or
below compared to maintaining current
policies
let's turn our attention now to
regulatory and economic instruments and
policies which play a critical role in
strengthening the response to climate
change
regulatory and economic instruments
ranging from standards for vehicle
efficiency and building codes to
policies for industrial decarbonization
to broad-based carbon taxes and emission
trading systems
have already proved effective
in reducing emissions so such measures
can be strengthened and expanded
significantly
policy packages and economy-wide
packages are better able to achieve
systematic change than individual policy
instruments on their own
ambitious and effective mitigations
mitigation requires coordination across
government
setting and implementing strategies and
building consensus among disparate
stakeholders
these efforts are particularly effective
when built
on engagement with civil societies
indigenous people professional bodies
and businesses
in recent years there has been enormous
activities and significant progress in
technology and innovation which is
reflected in this assessment report of
working group 3.
investment and policies especially for
scientific training as well as research
and development
push forward low emission technological
innovation
key to effective decision making in
assessing the potential benefit and
risks of different technologies and
approaches understanding
their implementation at scale and
identifying what stand in their way
some options are technically viable
increasing effective
and generally supported by the public
which enable enables development in many
in many regions
examples include solar energy energy
efficient appliance improve forest and
crop
management and reduce food waste
other options face barriers that need to
be addressed before they can be
implemented at scale
adoption of low emission technologies is
low is slower in most developing
countries
particularly the less developed the less
developed countries due to their limit
is limited capacities
in our countries
actions to limit global warming that
result in why in wider benefits to
societies can increase the peace depth
and breadth of emission reductions
accelerated and equitable climate and
action in mitigating climate change and
adapting to
climate change impact is critical to
sustainable development
in this report we show how mitigation
goes hand in hand with achieving many of
the sustainable development goals
we see that equity and just transitions
can lead to deeper ambitions for
accelerated climate action
many countries and regions are already
applying
just transition principles
in our assessment
we look at how mitigation actions can
lead to sustainable development
here are two examples and let me start
with actions in urban areas
as we focus on just one option green and
blue infrastructure we we see that green
roof and facade networks of parks and
open space with lands and urban
agriculture can only can
not not only absorb and restore carbon
but at the same time achieve many other
sustainable development goals as you can
see
with a square in these graphs
for example they can reduce pressure on
urban server system reduce flood
risks and heat island effects they can
also deliver health benefits from
reduced air pollution
focusing now
on land use avoiding deforestation and
sustainably managing soils forests and
livestock can mitigate climate change
these actions align well with the
sustainable development and can also
result in responsible production improve
livelihood and food security
potential potential conflicts between
reducing emissions and sustainable
development particularly around land use
and the need to ensure access to food
water and energy can be managed with the
right policies investment and financial
partnerships
this this gives
an insight into the wider benefits of
mitigation our report provides a
comprehensive assessment of all these
and with a now for now i would like to
hand back to my colleague professor eske
gimeski
okay thank you ramon
climate change is the result of more
than a century of unsustainable energy
and land use and patterns of sustainable
consumption and production
and what this report has done is to show
how taking action now
can move us towards a fairer and more
livable world
and so just to sum it all up we know
what to do
we know how to do it and now it's up to
us to take action
thank you very much for this
presentation we are now opening the
floor for questions the first questions
are already with us
um i will direct the first one to uh
professor james key
your spm this is from the new scientist
magazine adam vaughn
your spm says that global emissions must
peak by 2025 and fall 43 percent by 2030
in quote in global modeled pathways that
limit warming to 1.5 with no or limited
overshoot at endpoint
what examples does the report hold to
suggest that this is feasible
and what glo uh the global emissions
rose 5.5 last year and have never fallen
that fast
yeah well what the report absolutely
makes clear is that we're not talking
about business as usual uh if we are
going to address the challenge of
climate change
so we just we don't look at the
immediate past and say we expect that
pattern to continue the message is very
clear the governments of the world have
asked of set targets in the paris
agreement are part of the paris goals of
limiting warming to 1.5 or maybe two
maybe two degrees and what we have done
is set out very clearly it's almost
through the laws of physics and
chemistry that that is what would need
to happen if we were to limit warming to
these levels
now we're very conscious of the question
about this big change of direction so
the report does contain within it lots
of assessments of the feasibility of the
individual options that deanna
especially
was taking us through and it also has an
assessment about the feasibility of
actually the kind of system changes that
would be needed
and just to say the longer we put off
action in terms of in terms of
addressing climate change the bigger the
feasibility challenges will be and that
is a very very clear message of the
report
thank you very much for that um the next
question is from deborah krall the
indigenous affairs reporter from arizona
republic
this is the question for diana
indigenous people fear that the move to
conserve more land will end up removing
them from those lands and result in not
only homelessness but decreasing
biodiversity that made them attractive
how could they be included in
conservation instead of being excluded
from their
ancestral home
thank you very much for that question
actually there are several aspects of a
report that are relevant to this
question for example first we show that
actually restoration of ecosystems and
preserving uh
some of the land in its original
ecosystem status is very important in
fact one of the most important options
are in
in our land how we can reduce emissions
what we also show that any option that
we want to implement will have negative
impacts on some
consumer groups or some stakeholders
some parts of businesses or
of the society and in order to manage
these the best option is to involve
these stakeholders from the beginning
of of planning these actions and we
especially emphasize indigenous peoples
that these are especially important to
involve also they can also have
special wisdom to us in which which we
can benefit from when we plan these
opportunities
thank you very much the next question is
from new hampshire public radio it's
directed to ramon
what is the role of local or state or
city or town governments in speeding
emissions reductions what goals should
they set and what actions can they take
first of all i would like to say that
when talking about solutions and
responding to climate change uh the the
starting point is thinking in terms of
inclusive actions that consider not only
the national governments but also a
a variety of
stakeholders including of course the
local communities including the the the
the subnational subnational air
governments but also participation of
a professional bodies businesses and
different different uh stakeholders that
of course it should be not only a part
of the problem but also part of the of
the solution and in that sense we have
been uh experimenting in the in the in
the in the recent past uh and i would
say a movement a trend to an
inconsiderable increase in the
participation of the subnational
entities and also local communities in
the context of looking for solutions
to
to climate change and this has to
certain to a certain extent also
encourage governments to take policies
and law associated as part of this whole
trend to this has encouraged and
to the national government to think and
to take uh
approved policies and laws that directly
or indirectly let's say for instance
through
energy policies and so on contribute to
a to climate a climate and climate
action contribute to climate responses
it's a crucial element indeed
thinking in terms of include the
inclusiveness it that is needed at
equity in terms of uh uh thinking on
policies and
responses to to climate change these two
a concept
as crucial as part of the the whole
concept of just transition i mean how
equitable is the is the process how
inclusive is the process and in that
sense the local communities the
indigenous people
and the other stakeholders i already
mentioned are crucial crucial components
crucial ingredients
thank you very much for that response we
have the next question from the times of
india and it's directed to the united
nations environment program executive
director inger anderson
the question is the following
many banks are promising to eliminate
fossil fuels advancements and corporates
are promising net zero which may not be
believed by everybody
the uns secretary general has formed an
expert group to take stock of the
progress of these claims
how do you feel
and how much this is possible and to
achieve net zero by 2050
i think we just thank you very much i
think we've just heard from the
presentation that it is a major shift
and that goes for government but it
certainly also goes for banking and so
accordingly therefore uh we are very
clear that it is easy to make the claim
and harder to deliver on this claim
whether it's on the government side on
the banking side but clearly what this
report makes absolutely clear is that
unless we do so we will not be having
the security of the investments that
people have made for the day after
tomorrow in the proverbial day after
tomorrow therefore making those shifts
early and early as early as possible is
critical in his statement the recorded
statement the secretary general spoke to
this exact issue
because the point is if i am a young
person and i start my pension today
start with a pension scheme today i
would very much like to have that pay
out when i reach early age so what is it
therefore that my pension is investing
in if i am an insurance company what is
it that i am investing the insurance
premium in if i am an asset holder what
is it that these assets are invested in
that's the issue within unifi and other
aspects we have indeed been working on
this
it with a
significant amount of resources signed
up um and but it isn't a hard issue and
the call is therefore on individual um
investors but also of institutions to
lead to lean in and make this happen
thank you
thank you thank you very much for this
response just to check if there are any
other additional comments from the
people in in the room no we are moving
on the next question is from the
associated press
and it's directed to uh
james key
at what date will it become impossible
even with drastic emission cuts to keep
temperature below 1.5 degrees celsius
the report says it is impossible under
current ndcs
and current policy
so um at what year do we pass the
crossroads dr lee mentioned where no
matter what we do can't prevent hitting
1.8 degrees
well i i think i would almost need to
consult my calendar
on that particular question because the
report is very clear that we need to
take action now or 1.5 degrees may
become simply beyond reach it may be
physically impossible uh to to to get
there
so uh the the the message is we don't
have a date i mean i think inger
anderson but you know when she was
talking she said no you do not this year
not next year this week not next week
today not tomorrow and that would really
be the message we need to get on with us
now or 1.5 degrees will slip beyond
reach and if there is no advance in the
kind of pledges that countries are
making uh you know before we get to cop
27 in egypt at the end of this year i
think you know it may well
we may well have to conclude that indeed
1.5 has gone though of course in longer
term throughout the 21st century there
are technologies there are approaches
that could draw carbon dioxide emissions
from the atmosphere
and actually start to bring temperatures
down
the issue there of course is that some
of the
the climate impacts are associated with
the peak temperature because
irreversible impacts may occur so
basically the strong it really
underlines that message about taking
very early action
thank you very much for that
next question is for diana it comes from
kate arnoff of the new republic
and the question is following in
response to high fuel prices and war in
ukraine the u.s and eu have signaled
they will build additional fossil fuel
infrastructure on either side of the
atlantic
much of which will stay online for
decades to come
are these build-outs consistent with
limiting warming to 1.5 degrees celsius
or 2 degrees celsius
thank you we do show that
fossil fuel infrastructure that we keep
building will some of that will be
stranded which means that we will not be
able to use it if we want to keep global
warming to 1.5 degrees in fact what we
show is that what we already presently
see or at least at the time when we
closed uh
when we finally looked at literature
which was last october that
approximately one to four trillion u.s
dollars worth of interest infrastructure
will be stranded which means that will
not be possible already to return that
fully their investments so building even
more infrastructure either puts our
puts reaching our climate goals at risk
or will just cause even more
infrastructure to be stranded and that
will have
negative impacts on the whole society so
we do need to make choices and
what our report shows that there are
also a lot of
opportunities through which we could for
example rapidly reduce
emission reduct emissions and energy use
for example
through individual action we can reduce
very rapidly by five percent our
emissions and also there are longer
longer-term opportunities through
the more rapid
acceleration renewable energy
technologies which are today among the
cheapest as already my colleague jim ski
has pointed out and many other options
which can help us to reduce our energy
use and also to
provide
more rapid
acceleration of alternative energy
sources which do not rely on fossil
energy production
thank you diana the next question is for
ramon
it is from andy reevkin
the report shows global greenhouse gas
emissions have continued to rise but
also says expanding
laws and policies quote have led to the
avoidance of emissions that would
otherwise have occurred end quote
given complexities like leakage
what's the evidence
for that conclusion
well first of all i would like to say
that
the policies and law uh is a part of the
of the of the institute the instrument i
could say do we to be applied in
responding to to climate change of
course having a policy having a law is
not enough it's a it's a precondition i
would say but to
to
having a result an effective result out
of that policies out of the of of those
laws necessarily we would need an
implementation process that as i said
before should be inclusive should be
effective should consider the different
the different participation of the
different
stakeholders and it is a a
a set of conditions that to be should be
taking into account to have a chance of
success as a
a as a result of this of this of this
process
reducing
energy emissions as has been already
mentioned by my colleague professor ski
a good requirement to if we we are think
if we want to to limit a
warming for instance to 1.5
degrees
celsius would imply
immediate
and significant reduction in the
greenhouse gases emission and also it
means accelerated mitigation but also it
should be equitable
mitigation so the policies and laws in
practice should consider this aspect
also in the in the implementation
process should consider this this aspect
that should be uh i could say a
precondition for a having a success as
part of those of those process i mean
the ensure the responses is not enough
having of course we have been
experimenting in the in the recent past
as a high as i
mentioned in my presentation there has
been an inconsiderable increase in the
adoption of policies and law and this is
a positive signal of course this is a
positive signal in terms of governance
in terms of
interest with regard to the to the to
the to to participating in the
solutions or responses to climate change
is a positive it's a necessary condition
but it's not a sufficient condition we
need to think also in the part of the
implementation and to to the extent that
that
those policies and law are not only
adopted but also a properly implemented
in an equitable a way and an inclusive
way and the an immediate
sense as has been mentioned of course it
could be successful otherwise we will
have we will be the gaps good remains
i think i believe professor ski also
wants to add on this question yeah i
mean i think it's a it's a really good
question to ask we can have laws we can
have things written on pieces of paper
but do they actually make a difference
on the ground and does it make a
difference to emissions now in fact the
report that we've written does assess
literature from quite a number of
studies that have tried to address that
question very directly some of the
studies by looking backwards on trying
to assess what kind of changes and
emissions have occurred
and other studies which kind of look
forward and and try to predict the
effects of policies and regulations that
have come into place so there are
actually specific numbers in the report
on specific numbers in the summary for
policymakers and some of the estimates
lead to to
a guess that you an estimate of about
maybe three and a half percent of
current global emissions our emissions
would have been three percent higher
hard we these laws and policies not
being put in place and other estimates
actually go much higher they suggest
that emissions would have been 10
percent higher than they they currently
are if we hadn't had these laws and
policies
so uh you know we can lament the for you
you we are beginning to slow the pace of
growth of greenhouse gas gas emissions
it could have been higher if if we had
not taken action and the challenge now
is really to step up the pace of that
action we have the tools we have the
regulations we have the policies we need
to make them tighter and we need to
spread them more widely in order to make
changes
thank you very much for that
contribution the next question is again
for diana it's from amy westervelt from
the guardian
can you speak to the roles
misinformation and greenwashing play in
impacting government's abilities to
effectively mitigate climate change
yes thank you for that question
we do show that there are many
opportunities and more and wider
opportunities available for both
governments as well as businesses to
take action and individuals as well
nevertheless we do show that there is a
significant implementation gap so the
promises of many
cities governments
businesses have not we don't see the
progress that they are they will be able
to reach their promises because there is
the emissions are not going in the
direction that where they would already
need to be if we were to fully reach the
targets that they have set nevertheless
uh we we also see that there is
significantly increased political will
and that will help us in reaching these
targets because for example as jim
already showed there are 18 countries
which have already managed to reduce
their missions as in response to their
climate change policies we also see that
a very large number of cities have
committed to net zero goals so that
means that there is increasing
commitment and when there is increase in
commitment there is also increasing um
attention to this we also show that
transparency reporting monitoring and
verification these are all key to
implementing our ambitious climate goals
and ambitious policies and we will only
be able to achieve the full impact of
these ambitions if we do implement also
these as part of the policies and also
different actions that businesses take
thank you very much for that response
the next question is again for the
united nations environment program
executive director it is from the
arizona republic
water security is a top and urgent
climate matter in the us desert
southwest along with other redefining
regions around the world what is the
single most important thing for people
living in those areas to understand
about what they can do now to protect
their access to critic to this critical
resource
thank you i mean i think it was the
second report of this crop of ipcc
reports that signifies that at some
point in a year 50 of the population are
likely to be living in scarcity and so
this is absolutely an issue so are we
then therefore in the in these scarce
areas and i will distinguish between
poorer regions such as a sahel and
a wealthier region such as arizona are
we in the wealthier areas where scarcity
prevails living as if we had no scarcity
are we
being mindful of the kind of restoration
activities ecosystem restoration
activities that we could do that would
enhance soil moisture and therefore
leave the little rainfall that there may
be
in the in the soil also at the same time
making them more fertile are we using
zero watering gardens what kind of
hardware uh and and machinery do we use
for that is water consuming and that is
otherwise in uh that could be more water
efficient do we understand that we can
in fact implement and have a much lower
water footprint while still living
healthy lives with parks and enjoyment
so it is around appliances it is around
awareness it is around use and it is
also around mindfulness around storage
and
and restoration in poorer zones such as
the sahalian belt from uh somalia on the
one end and to senegal on the other
clearly there it is about restoration
this is why the african union has
started the green the
african green belt that sees to and
looks towards restoring what has been
degraded over since the 70s when we have
seen this ever ever decreasing rainfall
year on year
driven on by climate change these are
the kind of actions that we can take um
and so that that does become very
critical if i just may on the issue of
policies the very issue is that having
policies that stick
that are as we heard also transparent
but also that are reported on by media
and held to account
that's a way that is where we see the
needle shifting the fastest declaratory
policies that are generic in nature are
not the way we will get there it is by
getting quite specific sector by sector
the building sector the construction
sector the transport sector as well as
the energy sector that's the way we will
get there and of course using
incentivizing with instruments be it
taxes or tax breaks to enable that these
policies are taken up more fast thank
you
thank you very much we are also seeing
some interest in the actual work of the
ipcc um the secretary mentioned in his
opening remarks the voluntary
contributions by states as well as the
pandemic so to summarize those um you
know you know two-part question what
kind of support the ipcc is is enjoying
from from the member states
and what has been the impact of the
coveted 19 pandemic this is a question
for dr abdullah moxie
thank you thank you andre
yes
ipcc is basing his work
on voluntary contributions
and i will use 3
v 3v
which is about financial voluntary
contribution
and as
ipcc work should be neutral because we
are assessing research
but we should really be neutral about
any kind of policy
this is why we are working
with voluntary contribution financial
monitoring contribution
the second v is
and this is
the big v
because it is based on
the voluntary contribution from
scientists
thousands of scientists
are contributing to do
high quality of the work of ipcc
and i think i am happy to see in this
press conference we have developed
country expert
women and as well as developing country
expert and this sixth cycle
thanks to the voluntary contribution
voluntary involvement for not only
balanced regional representation but
also
the openness for
new camera
new youth scientists and this is thanks
to this
great v we are providing good assessment
the other v is little bit
specific for ipcc because ipcc is the
best interface between policy and
science and we were not about
to achieve an approval if we didn't have
voluntary
you know disposition
from
government to listen to scientists to
come with a consensus and also sort of
summary policy maker
you know does
bring
governments and scientists in same table
yes of course
sixth cycle it was a little bit
you know particular because it was the
most intense in the history of the ipcc
we provided they are releasing ac report
but also
we face it
the kovit 19 pandemic
and i am happy to say that
for the tree report three contribution
working group one working group to work
on group three
approval session
all this
approval session were handled in virtual
platform
and this of course requested a huge
ic support huge mobilization but there
are also some
positive aspects i can just give you the
example of disciplinary we did have
almost 1 000
registered delegation 1 000
participants were participating or the
negotiation of this
plenary because it is virtual but of
course we demonstrated that
we managed
the pandemic the pandemic didn't stop
ipcc to deliver
and
we are hoping next time you can have it
we have it in person but anyway
we will be able
to use this virtual platform to manage
any situation
thanks to all the disposition and all
the collaborative work and this is
something i want to also to highlight i
think this cycle was also a
demonstration that there was
excellent collaboration between
the three working group of ipcc as well
as between
the secretary up and all the technical
support unit under this three working
group this is what i want to say thank
you
thank you very much i believe the chair
of the ipcc would also like to add a few
words
yes thank you a couple of minutes ago
there were questions about the
effectiveness of climate delegation and
also some policy instruments and these
very very important questions and as i
just want to highlight a couple of data
ar6 found
that is the consumption-based
co2 emissions
declined in developed countries this
implies that the co2 intensity in the
developing countries declined
this is the example of a very positive
policy spillover
across the borders
and
policies
positive policies
actions taken in developed countries or
some other countries
have a spillover effect so
we can be very optimistic about this
direction of
very
ambitious action in the countries
thank you very much dr lee the next
question is from
laurie gearing from the thompson reuters
foundation it is for ammon
what are now the major barriers to
achieving the transition needed social
financial
what in simple terms needs to change to
bend a curve that is so far not being
bent
thank you very much i could say that
this question refers to some elements
which are crucial
in the financial in the
debate
on climate change and also for finding
solutions or responding to climate
change with regard to the social issues
i would like to highlight that this is
the
this sixth assessment report the
contribution of working group group
three to this sith assessment report of
the of the ipcc this is the first time
that a whole chapter has been devoted to
analyze the demand side and the demand
the social aspect of mitigations
including a aspect related to the demand
side
solutions and responses to to climate
change and this is an issue of course as
was mentioned by by diana in her
presentation there is a huge uh
potential for reducing emissions on the
demand side and in that sense social
aspect in terms of
changes in behavior and other social
social
elements could be could contribute to to
realize this this a huge potential in
terms of
of the demands
actions we in in the in the on the
demand side
but of course there are talking about
barriers and of course there are social
barriers
as those associated to the social
behavior behavior but there are other
crucial barriers that has to do with uh
with
what is also mentioned in the question
which is finance technology and this is
crucial for uh particularly those
excitement of the well economy which are
much more vulnerable and they are the
developing countries and within the
developing countries for instance those
which are much more vulnerable as a
small island developing states and the
less developed countries
finance with regard to finance there is
also a
an extensive assessment of the financial
aspect in this
a contribution of working group three to
the 6th assessment report and in that
sense it is clear that there are there
is a gap
there is a a gap with regard to the
existing financial flows oriented to
climate action and
the requirements to uh
the financial requirement to advance in
the in limiting uh
warming to 1.5 or 2 degrees celsius and
in contrast to this to this to this gap
there are there are capitals available
there are a
liquidity available so the the the point
is uh if we want really to to advance in
that in that path of limiting
warming following those ambitious goals
we need to think in terms of
firstly addressing those those gap and
this is a
signal for government for the
international community
also in terms of international
cooperation but but because of finance
and technology are two
key aspects that in terms of barriers
and in terms of the the needs of
developing a country for fully
participate in the
in this response to this global response
to climate change that that should be a
properly properly addressed and this has
also to do with the articulation the
connection of the climate climate
response to the sustainable development
goals i mean these are two sides of the
same coin i would say
for progressing for advancing and and
and
sustain this the the accomplishment of
those goals we necessarily need need to
think
uh in terms of an accelerated response
to climate change and accelerated
mitigation as part of that response but
this
accelerated process should also be
equitable as has been already said and
this is also another issue that did
need to be properly addressed as part
when thinking in terms of barriers for
for further for further progress in that
in that sense with regard to technology
technology development technology
transfer is another aspect that was
assessed in this contribution of working
group three and uh of course that
this is another area in which much more
effort would be needed uh if we
i mean want to advance in the with this
with limiting the
the warming in those directions take
into account these two ambitious world
1.5 and the degree celsius and two
degrees they research so in general i
would say that this aspect
when the the the responses or the
potential responses to climate change
particularly in ter in terms of
mitigation which is the mandate the the
the main
objective of this working group three
when talking about mitigation as part of
the of the responses to climate change
the assessment of not only of the
potential but also of the barrier has
been a crucial a crucial aspect and
of course the the intention is keeping
this as a relevant areas uh
within the with the the work of the of
the ipcc
always considering that the mandate of
the ipcc is assessing relevant
literature with regard to these issues
and others without being prescriptive in
terms of the
the i mean the prescribing prescribing
policies
thank you very much ramon i believe
co-chair uh james key also has something
to add on this question yeah very
specifically on finance i mean we have a
dedicated chapter on investment and
finance in in the report and what it is
trying to do is really to explain the
issues about how you close that gap and
get enough money moving into the kind of
mitigation projects that we need and
what's very clear
public money can't do it by itself i
mean developed country governments have
not met their hundred billion uh dollar
a year goal but the money that is needed
is actually in the trillions it's not
not a matter of billions so we need to
get private sector money going as well
and they're the important thing is that
the public sector and governments use
the money that they have cleverly in
order to incentivize uh private sector
investments so the challenge there is in
many developing countries the cost of
capital is high so public governments
need to put in place steps and use
instruments that bring down that cost of
capital to make the projects more
investable and that means things like
loan guarantees export credit etc to
make sure that the projects become
investable and that's got to be a big
part it's not just about uh public money
coming through which may be important
especially for adaptation projects
but from the mitigation side it's
reducing the risks of investing in the
project from pension funds insurance
companies etc
thank you very much for that just to
alert our panelists we have about eight
more minutes to go we'll try to squeeze
as many questions as possible please
bear that in mind
the next question is from janessa.com
from eos
um it's possibly first for diana perhaps
the chair my co-chair might want to also
add something to it
here's the question panemic pandemic
shutdowns led to the largest annual drop
in global energy related carbon dioxide
emissions since world war ii and brought
broad economic pain
how does the scale of the drop in 2020
compared to what's needed each year to
limit warming at 1.5 or 2 degrees
celsius and what essential
what is essential for limiting economic
strain
thank you very much and that's a very
important question because uh of course
it emerges in us that uh if this uh
substantial reduction is around five to
six percent reduction is what is needed
each year to reach our climate goals to
keep global warming at one and a half
degrees then does it mean that we have
to be all locked up and and
go through these austerities to reach
our climate goals but our report shows
that in fact
there are the opportunities that we show
have actually
options to improve our lives so we show
many many options for example
if we design cities better that means if
we don't have to
get into our cars to travel far away
because the jobs and the homes and the
shopping are near to each other and we
are able to walk or we are able to cycle
because there is a safe and bicycle
infrastructure this actually doesn't
only cut greenhouse gas emissions
significantly but will also
help
us with being more healthy and also
cutting urban air pollution that is also
one of the biggest sources
of uh
air pollution related uh health effect
and death so
coming back to the pandemic the pandemic
gave us also many further opportunities
for example the fact that we are now
discussing online and have this press
conference online this has been made
increasingly acceptable and increasingly
possible as a result of the pandemic
because we are
improving our digital infrastructure and
digital and access to digital services
and generally
accelerated digitalization which is
shown in our report to be a fundamental
part of many of our responses
nevertheless the pandemic also increased
many of these barriers that have been
just discussed for example it needs to
be acknowledged that hundreds of
millions got were pushed back into
extreme poverty also many countries have
accumulated substantial debt and that
will also be an important barrier to
them responding to climate change
nevertheless further opportunities come
through the our responses to the
pandemic as already mentioned
earlier in this press conference that
many governments are mobilizing
substantial resources to revitalize
their economies and how these resources
are spent is really critical to reach
not only to
again bring the economies back
and bring those people out again out of
poverty but this can be very well also
utilized for reaching our climate goals
and here it gives me also a good
opportunity to come back to the previous
question and add some further
information on the previous question
related to fossil fuel investments
because if we invest in
low
for example zero energy buildings which
i've already mentioned that these are
becoming increasingly available all
throughout the world also
we can now retrofit buildings to be net
zero these give us opportunities not
only to cut
our energy use but also to improve the
health and well being of the people and
the pandemic has shown that this is very
important because
we are
spending increasing amounts uh at home
and
so the point is that all together this
pandemic has yes
shown that we can reduce emissions but
that's not the way how we will have to
reduce emissions but there are many
opportunities through the responses to
the panamic which will
can accelerate our actions so that we
can reduce
uh our energy use and related emissions
in the scale that was as a result of the
pandemic
also if we can go to uh co-chair yeah
let me be quick uh look looking at the
time we've got we've got a new chapter
on demand and consumption and what that
makes very clear it's not human behavior
alone that is going to get emissions
down it's a mixture of access to and
provision of infrastructure and
technology and of course during the
pandemic it was all done by human
behavior we all locked ourselves up in
our homes and didn't travel that's not
the way to get emissions down in the
long term because you will not see the
social acceptability of such an approach
so i think there are very big
limitations to the analogy between the
kind of experiences we had especially in
2020
and
how you would go about getting demand
and emissions down in the long term that
needs planning it needs investment in
infrastructure it needs provision of and
access to technology
okay
thank you very much for that i believe
this is going to be our last question
it's from against efe from marta montojo
and on this one perhaps i will direct it
first to ramon and then perhaps maybe an
additional comment from
the co-chair
james key what sort of climate
mitigation policies that have been put
in place so far has had a short-term
negative impact on vulnerable low-income
groups and small companies as the
authors suggest
and how can governments avoid having
such an impact going forward
how much can we rely on the cdi
technologies
dioxide reduction technologies
uh well with regard to this uh last part
of the of the
of the of the question
uh a cdr is a has been also assessed of
course as part of the of this assessment
of the working group 3
and has been considered mainly the
different options that were
mentioned by my colleague diana and
for instance include
let me take one of those of those
options uh in the in the with regard to
land-based
solutions or land-based
mitigation in that case for instance
reforestation
reduce
reforestation reduce
deforestation could be a part of this
but because contribute to the
capture
capture of carbon the in that in that
case biological
sequestration of carbon and in that
sense it has a positive a positive
effect in terms of contributing to a
climate change mitigation i mean as part
of this the the positive size of this
technology but we need to take into
account that when applied at very large
scales many of these technologies
cdr technology can have also adverse
effects in terms of the implications of
the impacts with regard to the other
land uses that has to do for instance
with the food security but also with the
the soil the the health of those
ecosystem they could
imply the soil deterioration it can have
negative implications for biodiversity i
mean all these
a potential side effect effect that in
many cases are associated to the scale
in which these technologies are applied
were assessed in the in the in the in
this contribution of working group 3. of
course as i said this cdr
technologies are not only considered for
land-based uh uh responses it's two
there are other other other options as
that were also mentioned in terms of the
ocean geological sequestration uh and so
on but i i took this specific example
with regard to the land land
responses because
there we can see many of these of these
positive in terms of mitigation and
adverse
side effect with regard to the other a
negative implication in other in other
areas
thank you very much coacheski yeah okay
that was two massive questions for for
the price of one there uh actually uh
just that just thinking about about
potential negative effects and they
don't have to be negative if they're
managed properly for example the move to
electric vehicles they're more expensive
to buy and they're cheaper to run and
that can affect people on low incomes
who don't have the access to the capital
uh to to take them up so that's the kind
of thing where you need the policies in
place to actually make it work and make
it equitable
you can also pick up areas of combat
converting agricultural land for
planting trees that can displace people
on interacts with land tenure systems so
again these are the kind of of issues
that need to be managed and on carbon
dioxide removal i mean the chapter that
we have on this that includes this is
very clear that there are very diverse
number of approaches technologies
measures that count as carbon dioxide
removal and they all need to be
addressed very carefully some are
land-based as ramon has said some are
very engineering and technical and each
has their own challenge but i'd
completely agree with ramon that it's
the land-based ones where you need to
look out very carefully for the the
social equity just transition kind of
issues
thank you very much and actually the
last question is also for you it is from
the washington post
and it's the following
the report makes that politics not
science technology or lack of
understanding is the main barrier to
achieving emissions reductions
which political players have been the
main obstacles to climate action
how must politics now change to enable
the energy transition to occur
uh andre you saved the most difficult
question for the last and the one when i
need to be most delicate one because it
is not ipcc's job to comment on the
policies of individual con countries or
organizations we have a chapter on
institutions governance and policy that
very carefully assesses the literature
around these particular areas and i
think what it actually does does is to
step back a little from actually asking
questions about green wash and whose
obstacles to think carefully about how
policies are formed and the role of
different stakeholders in policy
formation and it then has a much wider
reach because of course ngos and civil
society are also playing a big role in
influencing climate policy and we flag
up the role for increasing role of
climate litigation which may not only
affect governments but may affect
private sector uh actors as well so as
you know we're trained to deflect
questions like that and i i hope i've
deflected it uh sufficiently thank you
thank you very much and before we close
i would just like to invite the chair of
the ipcc question lee
for to share any closing remarks he may
have with us
i thank you very much and this report as
you know very well is released
under the rising
oil prices
and
the
oil prices is changing
almost every day and remember two years
ago around this time exactly
april 20th of 2020 the oil price was
minus 40 dollars per barrel so this is
the world
and therefore
this increases
rapidly rising oil prices is just a
would be just a blip
in our journey to
the path to net zero and the world
sooner or later we realize that
this net zero path would be independent
of changes in oil
prices our data support that
this three report indicated that for
last 10 years
the co2 intensity declined globally
regardless of changes in the oil prices
which is very volatile
so we wish to convey that message to the
world
thank you very much i wish to thank all
of the panelists for their time today
and for sharing the scientific findings
of the working group three report the
third contribution to the sixth
assessment cycle which will be concluded
in autumn this year when the synthesis
report will be again delivered to the
public to the world i would also like to
thank the representatives of the media
for attending this press conference take
care and see you soon bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you